you see that [ __ ] it's sunset
what if okay so imagine for a second
imagine imagine imagine imagine for one
second ice cream popsicle is I can't
even comprehend rare eating and milking
ice cream
popsicle people only purchase solid ice
cream
late evening sir and that's what we have
to be doing and what we're gonna be
doing is we're gonna put it all in our
van a vehicle and nazia putting these on
our van and then we're gonna be going
out in the evening because it is just
thing dusk right now and we can purchase
some stuff cruise around town blast out
that typical ice cream truck music and
we're gonna get some purchases oh god
damn it okay
no oh God ice cream cone that works yeah
done just like that just made it more
defined much better oh oh it's getting
worse kissing what it's getting worse
it's worse okay all right
Marga Blair's ice cream boutique it'll
do okay Oh God first stop ice cream I'm
gonna call Bob just in case Bob's got
some advice hey Josh
hey hey so we are currently in the
process of getting an ice cream truck
for the van and I just wanted your
advice on the best way to execute that
yeah yeah because the way I figured like
it's it's dark out right now it's
getting dark there aren't any ice cream
trucks that run out in the evening but
in evening is when everyone wants
dessert good idea why why would we okay
all right
anyway all right thank you all right see
see yeah all right thanks
all right bye so creepy no dice cream
fun with the whole family
at night okay we gotta go get some stuff
so you're right the profits from our
last pop-up shop go to the profits for
our next ice cream truck I like it
BAM excuse me
whoa privacy please I've got scribblers
hahaha rainbow always fun with grape
orange cherry all classic and I've got
these sweet crunchy drumsticks I love me
some butter pecan of all businesses
start out small they may seem like
they're not very much or they're weird
or in a creepy van or in a dark scary
hallway with a knife but some businesses
start out small and grow into something
big okay let's do
[Music]
ma'am ice cream
gets him someone's honking for ice cream
yellow why yellow that's like the least
alright
$300
[Music]
mijo your fries you're such a good
salesman I'm hungry for ice cream that's
what they got a see they got a see
people eating it
it's so good fun fun fun fun I ain't
gonna work we got to find a place where
we can sell ice cream to these people
where they need it the most so what we
have here is a advertising problem the
highway didn't work because well not
because of us who it's because people
didn't know what they were getting they
couldn't really see the experience going
on they couldn't see it just lusciously
getting down my garlic and that's what
people need so I'm gonna do is we're
gonna showcase exactly what we got going
on here Lane I am okay so that's two
they may have thirty seven flavors but
we got we got chica we got chica I'm
with chica she's a biggest selling point
that we can ever hope for
right chica what's that why why whatever
we're at a secluded location a Costco
parking lot it's closed but we don't
care about that they won't be our
competitor for now what we do you need
to get customers so I'm gonna tell
people that working here and it's gonna
be totally chill mistake I made last
time is I didn't emphasize that it was a
happy friendly experience so I'm gonna
say markup liars friendly ice cream
truck come get your ice creams ice cream
truck is open for business
it was my script what we need is some
sweet music I mean the image is right
but I don't know if that's that doesn't
feel right
[Music]
no-nothing friendlier now is wait for
the customers to roll in
oh I don't forgot yeah we're not ready
we're not ready I forgot I didn't put
the other flavors up on the thing Wow
customers riding with the ice cream
trucks told everybody just give us two
two minutes
there's my amortize hauled of flavored
oil is ready elephant yeah two seconds
hot cheese okay all right um welcome to
uh market lars friendly ice cream truck
what uh what would you like a rainbow I
need the music going hand we really got
a pump
[Music]
[Applause]
okay alright enough goofing around here
do I have to do all the work sir thank
you how about a would you what would you
like okay cool there you go
that'll be $50 okay so they ran off but
that's not bad because they'll be it's
good for business just forget about it's
good for business we got all the
advertising we got the music ready to go
when it's going we got the ice cream why
do you still have those if there's one
person that knows exactly what goes on
in the business strategy it's Tyler he
is a masters in sports a hello Tyler are
you there yeah okay hey how's it going
okay so we got an ice cream truck I just
want to run a few things by you you tell
me if it's a good idea or bad idea we
got our ice cream in our ice bucket
we've got the jam and tunes right there
they're not playing right now let me see
if I can we've got me at weight we got a
customer there it is hang on hang on
hold on wait why Tyler are you there
we're open for business
where's your face hello good customer
you can see all of our flow yeah is she
available for sale
no what flavor would you like oh well I
do think of the ice cream part we said
an ice cream truck comes to go here
drumstick I'm feeling a cherry popsicle
okay all right you get him the cherry
popsicle I'll get the drumsticks okay
be right there all right sighs we got to
go we got customer make it two for the
price of nothing
what no they're their $50 you didn't
even pay you think you could run Oh
be quick
he's real quick ok what do you want Oh
sick drumstick run out drums Oh show
your face around here again you better
welcome okay who wants some ice cream
yeah it's just some ice cream what do we
got
it's right there oh my reading
comprehensions nothing you don't even
have to read this colors and shapes
let's take a drumstick we did not
we've got butter pecan ice cream as well
in the tub I'll do it elder the tub
cream drip the top cream we got it all
right that'll be $50 deal you want a
liquid her card why is your cash liquid
because I can't grab it like this and
have a baby dry that's for you babe what
do you want right there okay all right
thank you guys so much for not paying
all right we are sold out of ice cream
again but unfortunately we didn't make a
goddamn penny because nobody paid
anything for what they were supposed to
get bang either way it was fun I think
we got the word out we can write that
all off as advertising in people's minds
when they think of ice cream they think
of me anyway thanks so much for all the
help as usual that was really fun let me
know if you figure out what we should do
in the future in thanks again and as
always I'll see you in the next one bye
bye